multiverse multiverse bro
yes yeah man so i heard the album uh
about two months ago and i was [ __ ]
gone off with some mushrooms okay okay
and you play the album like eight or
eight times in a row in the studio and i
was just sunk into the couch and it
sounded like the greatest [ __ ] i've ever
heard in my life i don't know why
everybody keeps doing like hell and
mushrooms around me and getting [ __ ]
up
yeah so it's funny though yeah look what
i heard was amazing i changed it a lot
from there i've heard i've heard that
i've heard there's some new stuff
because i feel like memory lane i didn't
i don't know if i heard memory lane no
that song wasn't recorded at that time
there was uh there's still some songs
from that time that are in there on the
album but no i kind of i reworked it i'm
still reworking it like the [ __ ] comes
out on friday i'm still reworking it
like right now what's like the absolute
latest you could turn it in though um
well there's there's ways of going about
it there's the music side there's the
artwork side there's the track listening
side so there's just things that you can
still you know get and work in your
favor so let's say there's samples that
just got cleared last week you know what
i mean so thursday 7 pm comes and you
decide track 2 feels like a track 12. i
could do that you could do that yeah
yeah okay
as possible you know that that happens
anything's possible yeah yeah uh why
multiverse
um
[ __ ]
it started out kind of just being like a
name that i landed on
and then it started to just you know
take its own life and just be this world
that i kind of exist in on my own and
then when i listen to the music i'm like
it really is my own multiverse it's me
showing different sides of myself and
it's also uh me not chasing any trends
or trying to sound like anything that's
being done
so it's it's something that on its own
you know what i mean it stands out on
its own in its own yeah when i heard
like at least the version i heard i felt
it was like a nice representation of
like everything you can do yes for sure
because you got trap whiz you got
there are so many things you can you you
you are like capable of doing like a
[ __ ] well i am a martial artist but
it's like martial arts i got so many
different styles and to bring them all
together and just use them where they're
appropriate um that was the goal and to
also just show off and flex a couple
different skills that people you know
might or might not associate with you
know my legacy so uh yeah